Pregnancy seems like a miracle, but when people
start basing health advice on that sentiment
that’s how problems start.
Luckily, I've brought this science with me.
Let's look it over, shall we?
I've got a pal who just announced she's preggers,
and being pregnant comes with all sorts of
strange conversations about health which would
NOT be okay in any other situation.
When you're pregnant, strangers will throw
shade at you for being in a sushi restaurant,
at Starbucks, or on an airplane…
Everyone's got opinions, but do they have
facts to back it up?
A big myth about pregnancy concerns fish.
Fish is a staple of a healthy diet, and pregnant
women are encouraged to eat fish -- but it
DOES contain trace amounts of mercury.
But not all fish are equal, so you just need
to eat the right fish.
No yellowtail or bigeye tuna, but salmon is
great!
Check the full lists online When ingested,
methylmercury is absorbed by the central nervous
system and can impair normal brain development
in children, infants and fetuses.
Other studies have connected methylmercury
consumption during pregnancy to ADHD, especially
in boys.
Just remember FISH is GREAT for pregnant women
-- it's brain food after all!
Plus it contains omega-3s and decreases cognitive
decline in older people
Coffee is another thing pregnant women get
judgement for drinking.
But in general, coffee won't harm a fetus.
Some studies say drinking caffeine can increase
risk of miscarriage, stillbirth, or other
weight problems.
This means tea SHOULD be two sides to the
same leaf, but it isn't.
Fortunately for caffeine lovers, research
isn't entirely clear -- even if the media
hype makes it seem like it is.
Yes, caffeine IS a stimulant, which may cause
problems in large quantities, but drinking
less than 200 mg per day is fine.
200 mg is like, one 8 to 10 ounce cup of coffee,
depending.
Studies show eating peanuts while pregnant
will decrease the chances of the baby developing
an allergy to peanuts.
Not to mention, peanuts are a great source
of folic acid and protein!
Though research is still ongoing, avoiding
them altogether doesn't seem to be necessary.
Sometimes, you get chocolate in my peanut
butter! AND THEN there's some serious opinions
thrown around.
A study published in Early Human Development
surprisingly found preggo moms who ate chocolate
also have happy babies.
Their study of 300 Finnish women found those
who'd reported eating a bit of chocolate daily
had a "positively reactive" baby -- also known
as a baby who smiled and laughed a lot.
But be cautious, they didn't say it CAUSED
a happy baby, just that they're correlated.
Speaking of chocolate and smiling … pregnancy
and sex has a LOT of myths surrounding it.
You can still have sex when you're pregnant.
The baby is surrounded by the uterus, and
an amniotic sac, the cervix has a mucus plug
sealing it shut, and the benefits of hormone
release during sex and orgasm are well documented.
The contractions from orgasm are completely
different muscles from those in the uterus
-- so get jiggy with it!
That being said, STIs CAN affect the fetus;
so make sure all parties are clean and practice
safe sex.
Some other myths that have been debunked by
science: go get your hair did.
There's no evidence hair dye harms the fetus
in the least; alcohol isn't great but if you
slip up you're not going to mess up your kid;
hot dogs, eggs and chickens are all fine,
just make sure they are well-cooked!
Something I was surprised by, is heat -- pregnant
moms should try and keep their body temperature
below 102 (40C) -- so no jacuzzis, saunas
or hot yogas.
Pregnancy can be scary, especially if its
the first time.
You don't get a do-over, after all, but all
the science says don't cut your diet to only
the "safest" foods, instead just eat healthily:
lots of fruits and vegetables, some meat and
fish some dairy and grain.
Keep it colorful!
We all want to believe that these wives tales
have been passed down and carry water, but
some of them are just plain made up.
Do you have a science question?
That's why were here!
Let us help!